you know I don't really have armrest
ever when I film wow how's it feel too
relaxed I feel like it's going to limit
my engagement and my sharpness you look
very calm very I know I'm out of my
realm citizens of the reject Nation I
have rewatched the entire Goosebump show
and read all the books in preparation
for this movie wow that's true
dedication that's true dedication not a
lie at
[Music]
all I also did the same definitely
didn't just watch it as a kid and forget
everything I saw when I was a
child The Nostalgia is going to play
heavily on us what are we watching they
watching the Goosebumps movie I've heard
it's a fun one Aaron you're the only
other person I know that hasn't seen it
are you excited yes is because it has
Jack black and has black in his name is
that why you picked
me save the racist jokes for bab I
thought that okay that's you that's a
you thing one thing to play off your
racist joke I take the power back if I
can make the racist job yeah yeah now
it's empowering it is
can ladies and gentlemen you know what
to do leave a like on this video I guess
I'm just all pinked up today like I'm
super pink I'm super pink subscribe
click the notification Bell cuz we got
other movies we covering this month Aon
is also covering a bunch with like
terara Andrew it's it's good good month
good month for movies lastly full in
watch long resync with your own copy
available for super sex reject over at
our patreon page fre sync up with your
own copy we cover sever things exclusive
the reaction H watchong included this
intro is
[Music]
done oh this feels like it's going to be
like some fun spooky fun yeah the the
music's giving like fun spooky I don't
know reminds me of Haunted Mansion
Madison
Delaware wow Mom are you positive that
there were't any other places looking
for vice principles it's Holly from the
office Amy Ryan do you have you Michael
scottw girl wife lady and that's the kid
from 13 Reasons Why yeah
whatever H's
[Music]
back fun vo I I know the feeling of
having a new neighbor and wondering
who's there I am that I am that
creepiest I
am you hear that no I don't hear
anything exactly hi from New York get my
sister Gail a special guest my nephew Z
oh my God the quirky loud
sister oh it's just a beautiful boy and
thank God cuz you were such an ugly baby
there it is he's handsome now it's not
like he's going to go ugly handsome and
then back to ugly actually it happens
more often than you
think this is from my new signature
men's line go your shirt it's limited
edition so you're not going to see a lot
of men wearing that PCH yeah I know I
can't imagine anyone would be wearing it
so limited
[Music]
edition smooth love when that
happen love interest Girl Next Door how
long was the drive from New
York no I can just tell by the pretty
hat that you
have it's actually a gift from my aunt
it's also a gift for me and everyone who
gets to see you wearing it I like
sarcastic [__] strangers I got to go
good
talk there he is there he is you stay
away from my daughter you stay away from
me we won't have a problem goofy but I
would also be a little scared you that
had intense eye contact well just met
our neighbor oh Mr Shivers yeah he moved
to town a few years ago very mysterious
very sexy I love his scent it's like
mint and
Bo peculiar I remember that
day Papa maybe Mr Shivers could be your
new
daddy daddy
Shivers you ready honey you okay um yeah
just found some more baby pictures I
really did look like baby
gollem masking your pain with sarcasm
how
unrelatable people don't do that new
friends new
friends what do you think you're doing
I'm going to work going to do some
educating some
administrating I love her so much she's
such a good actress yeah she's awesome
not sure walking in with the vice
principal is the play give me a 60c head
start so I at least have a chance you
promise you'll give it a shot you know I
can't promise you that a come on
embarrass him
I promise all right come on you're
better than that 60 second start now 60
58 I hope she has the same class with Mr
shiver's
daughter okay let's settle
down okay cool okay oh you're the Corky
comedic best friend okay am so happy to
introduce you to our new vice principal
Miss Cooper and I hope that you show her
the same
that you show me Bowser who did that
I'll whoop your ass you can't say that
yeah I can you're in the room with
me I thought we the ru not until we make
a handshake then you get the these rules
are so complicated you taking anyone to
the dance okay no hey we should go
together no no not like together
together dance together or anything
although that could work you know we get
the crowd into it you know and then go
split off with different girls yeah
that's how they would read
it I like how this cinematography has
progressively gotten darker and grayer
someone
there did I scare you no really because
you jump like 10 ft high is she an
actual daughter or like
creature cuz the way they capture her
like for povs feel like she's not a
human is she a werewolf so is there
anything like fun to do around here okay
there is one thing that I like to do eat
humans come with me if you want to
[Music]
live damn he loged out getting a next
door neighbor who's like a a teenager
you a cute girl teenager friend like oh
my God that's like the dream when you're
a teenager the dream this guy's like
living a movie are you taking me someone
to kill me I'm just curious I'm playing
it by
year she means that I don't think she's
human I think she's something more
Hannah yes Zach Follow The Stranger into
the
woods she's a
bird come on scaredy cat we're almost
there might be a clue scurity cat you
might be right the werewolf thing think
you're on or something by the way if my
theories don't come true I'm going to be
pissed off at the movie it's how I
operate as a viewer if I'm not right the
movie is bad watch this
[Music]
whoa o what a find wow how the hell is
this just in the middle of the woods how
do the lights still work City didn't
turn the power off in this place they
built it years ago but then they ran out
of
money now it just sits here but still
gets power yeah that's a great question
eron it's a great
question why did you move to Madison my
mom said to me Zach if you can live
anywhere in the the world where would it
be can I please move to Madison Delaware
that' be my dream are you always the
sarcastic always no that's a strong word
not always usually makes you likable
it's just been me and my mom since my
dad died last year so yeah I'm sorry oh
my god dude you can totally get her with
the
sympathy who's your dead dad get the
[Laughter]
pity how do we get down
oh I'll fly us
down I mean it's nighttime so she can't
be a werewolf it's only on full depends
on the moon what yeah it depends on the
moon yeah you know I'm probably going to
take out the trash on Tuesdays and
Thursdays so you know you feel like
creeping up on someone that works for me
I can take your trash out too if you
want I'll keep that in mind scaredy cat
Hannah what are you doing out here I'm
so sorry I'm just smoking cracked this
is your last warning you stay stay away
from us or something very bad will
happen I believe
you there are some very interesting
choices to to capture like stuff in in
their first person point of view you
don't see that too often because they do
it interchangeably between Hannah and
Jack
Black allow to can lock me up all the
time she is not human she ain't human
uhoh oh my God he thinks he thinks
domestic violence is happening what's
going on plot twist it really is just
domestic
violence what I heard a scream is hand
okay there was no scream you didn't hear
anything get out of here with the last
scream you'll ever hear would
be I really like Jack Black's
performance yeah it's different for him
never seen him do something like that
count 911 hi yes uh I live on Monroe um
uh it's an emergency I think yeah maybe
of possibly a a domestic disturbance I
don't
know Bad News
Bears you're under
arrest I love that keep it we're not
there
yet that's so
funny it's a domestic disturbance
absolutely right strange because I've
been here alone all night and I haven't
heard a thing what is this Transatlantic
accent he's doing yeah he's doing it
from like a different time period Anna's
my daughter and she's been staying with
me for a while while her mother sorted a
few things out with her new
husband she flew back to London
yesterday morning that's creative as
[__] mhm thank you for your time I'm
sorry for the
disturbance npe that puts a wrench in
your
[Music]
story oh it's a movie surround sound I
didn't know being an audio file was a
crime
who is she she's my favorite one so
clever that's
funny thank you so much for stopping by
and bringing your delightful son and the
police the police hate coming into the
home of an upstanding citizen such as
yourself really sorry I obviously you're
seeing he senses something
chares nervous you're
sweating way too suspicious my friend up
tase him I'll tase
him you're so eager tell me you don't
believe him surround sound seriously
Zach enough go
home all right K coming through and
don't worry it's going to be all about
Zach tonight so we went out to Sushi on
Wednesday and we both ordered the
chicken teriyaki which like wa is Amy
Ryan not going to be the main character
with is going to be this woman I feel
like she's going to come back she's the
administrator of the school she says
stop dating losers and never go on a
plane I knew it you know I I totally
forgot I have a huge test on Monday that
I got to study for don't come in my room
oh okay don't don't do that not cuz
you're boring or anything where are the
girls uh yeah about that I just said
that to get you over here I need your
help so there are no girls well there is
one girl a
m he can say it yeah well there's no
black people in
Madison so no one can hear
them how do you know this guy's going to
leave I called him and pretended to be
the cops and ask him to come to the
station dude you can get in big trouble
for that it's actually just a written
warning it's God damn he was hit his
head on the ground
Jesus a WWE over here what the
hell it's fun how they're painting Jack
Black like he's a bad
guy whoa where' you learn that Dad no
YouTube oh that makes more sense like
that more than played video
games tell I'm a good shooter stay here
and watch the driveway wait here by
myself yes champ you're the lookout if
sh comes back and Just Give Me A Sign
like I know use his name as an insult
[Laughter]
This
creepy it's her it's a warning sign
you're in the second
[Music]
acted what the H man you're supposed to
be the lookout yeah that's not going to
change I just be the lookout you know in
here you had one job let me explain
something to you Zacharias you know they
say teenagers have no fear of death well
not me okay I was born with the gift of
fear okay I remember being for being
pushed on a swing and thinking this is
how it
ends oh bear
traps oh my God who puts bear traps in
their basement I mean seriously oh my my
God someone who has a monster problem
the Scarecrow Walks at Midnight the
ghost next door Night of the Living
Dummy That's a classic the Abominable
Snowman of Pasadena my grandma losing
Pasadena and I stopped visiting after
reading this book that's not far from us
why are these books locked how would
lock a book maybe there's like a a key
or something we can unlock it with don't
do that look at this don't unlock that
book is for a reason now let's get back
to W oh
no Zach hey that was their plan for the
dance did you unlock a
book yeah I did I'll put it back where
it belongs and we'll be out of your hair
look here it is no don't open it oh what
have you done
[Music]
uh-oh
oh interesting Who
ah this makes a lot more sense now
[Music]
okay
whoa why would you write these books RL
[Music]
Stein
W there's like a Jumanji Night at the
Museum Vibe yeah yeah totally
totally
it's not a bad looking effect not bad
for almost 10 years ago man yeah
right what's going on nobody make a
sound you had one
job he had two jobs and you filled them
both oh
[Music]
[__] he's an Andrew and Roxy other's
opening on their own what I thought you
need the lock to do that come on come on
movie play by your own rules what are
the rules of your
universe that's the Abominable Snowman
you don't get that nickname by accident
and it just crawled out of a book that
doesn't just happen Zach I'm going after
Hannah hey that's the Abominable Snow
Man of Pasadena to you would have been
better if you didn't fumbled that yep
but you mumbled earlier so now we're
even what is she going to do read the
story I mean the plan to like capture
him put him back right yeah just clamp
him up he can't be killed
uhoh look above that a
Skittle why don't you look to where it
fell
from it's
candy
uhoh
CER
damn you
[Music]
strong a that's cute no you don't
understand the only way to stop them is
to suck him back into the book The Suck
back in no I'm not close
enough oh he seems so harmless until he
looks at you those eyes what are you
doing just open the book just wait why
don't you just leave you clearly don't
want to be here all lot of timing got
time oh no what are you
[Music]
doing oh my God does anyone know how to
play hockey here let get the
walk
yes come
[Applause]
[Music]
on
I like the idea quite a bit though
teenagers in Peril with the meta
commentary of like the Goosebumps coming
to life yeah so you get the Nostalgia of
the older people who did read it and
then with the kids nowadays and books
usually rob about kids it's very
clever what is happening I think ARL
Stein's behind
them
Papa got the
book Papa's going to get mad like I die
yep damn why does it look disturbing
when it happens it's so sad oh is he
turning into ink
[Music]
yeah this is sad wonder what the myth is
going to be around it like did he create
it or all of you in the car now I'm
going to guess he's RL Stein
[Laughter]
just a hunch you're RL Stein RL who I
don't know who that
[Laughter]
is just as well cuz his books suck
you're playing on his EO I'm so confused
you see the endings coming from a mile
away it's like stop trying to be Stephen
King man h no that the worst thing you
could
say let me tell you something about
Steve Kings
and I've sold way more books than him
but nobody ever talks about that okay
way more
books dad
go what if we're just watching one of
his books right now what if we're in the
book yeah there's a book within a book
hey hey what happens now you go home you
put on your PJs you get your blanket you
go napnap in the morning this will all
just feel like a bad dream Dad wait
there's no time start packing we're
moving again is it just his actual
daughter n she's a werewolf maybe he
married a werewolf or like a mermaid who
developed legs and now walks amongst us
humans not a normal family now go get
your things I'm so over
this
teenagers maybe she's been a teenager
for a very very very long
time old
team it's actually his wife I could have
killed
you that was a terrible
throat
when I was younger I suffered from
terrible allergies that kept me indoors
so I created my own friends monsters
demons that that happens and they became
real to
me and then one day it became real to
everyone my monsters literally leapt off
the page as long as the books remain
locked were safe but when they open
you've just seen what happens I love
that he still portrays it like he's a
like a Storyteller like he's almost
talking to the audience in a way keep
the manting plants away from the bug
eyed
aliens no uhoh not him hello Papa yes oh
it's is it who I think it is the dumy
the how long's it been you're so creepy
as a kid Slappy it's so nice to see you
did you miss me course I missed
[Music]
you oh
no so what what's the plan friend you
must have brought me out for something
fun terrorize the locals destroy the
town Let's Get Silly is that ham kind of
sounds like him going to destroy Madison
and I couldn't do it without you oh shs
you giv me oh what's the word Goosebumps
wait remember Jack Black oh you're right
you're trying to put me back in don't be
silly I know when you're lying to me
Papa he creepy you think yeah you've
made oh
no I think it's time I started pulling
the strings in this relationship tonight
is going to be the best story you've
ever written oh no uhoh so slopp is our
main antagonist he's the leader of
them oh no why would you just keep all
your books right there why don't you
keep him in a safe or
[Laughter]
something
a freshen up I don't remember the Gnomes
from the
oh really good effects yeah oh they're
cracking their their necks and their
hands damn that's a lot of
gnomes that is a little unsettling yeah
break them do get something that's on
your side friendly nope nope nope as
soon as he said that immediately no not
friendly definitely not
friendly look it looks like clamation
that's cool yeah to my face definitely
[Applause]
not yeah just smash them kick just smash
all of them get us a
gold actually like knock knocked out
yeah oh my
God no this feels like Army of
[Music]
Darkness thank you thank
you you can be more
effective throwing them in the oven oh
yeah you become Your Own Worst Enemy
Welcome to Hell oh
no can they
reassemble oh no oh it's smart they're
reversing it wa it's clever timing I
like how it looks actually in camera why
couldn't you've written stories about
rainbows and unicorns because that
doesn't sell 400 million copies oh
domestic no worldwide it's still very
impressive shut
up that's why Netflix always touts those
numbers oh she is human yeah I guess so
homeboy lives very under the radar for
someone that wealthy then again did you
know what ARL Stein looked like prior to
this movie I did he used to introduce
Goosebumps or do the epilog one of them
well I forgot why is he doing this so
there's no way to get the monsters back
inside it's Slappy's
Revenge Slappy's Revenge that's a good
title like he said it I was like good
title what is that thing I come in peace
I just want to read you a bedtime story
sir shut your mouth okay CU that's not
going to stop
me you've been relieved of your
duties now what are
[Music]
those oh
no it does a good job though even if you
haven't if you don't remember or know
the the Goosebumps creatures and stuff
they easily inform you yeah like all it
takes us to see what the creature does
really quick to understand what it is
yeah gets me curious to figure out the
other stories yeah sure you'll make your
time for that oh my God it's a floating
dog
[Music]
uhoh it's an alien dog alien
puppy that's
spooky damn they froze the town I just
love sets yeah that's really cool you
just don't get
sets production design building it this
would be in the volume if it was made
today if if you wrote The Monsters off
the page then maybe there's a way you
could write them back on do you have any
idea how many stories i' have to ride to
capture every monster I've ever created
I already have carpal tunnel in both
hands this is when Chad gbt comes in
handy okay well then we got to get you
to a computer so you can start writing
all right there's a look there's a
computer store right here get you break
in why don't you just write a new
character that take care of all the
other characters yeah the Superman of to
Wrangle them all in if I write on
anything else it won't work I need my
typewriter that typewriter is special it
has a soul of its own just write
Goosebumps the book the lead character
takes care of all the other
Goosebumps yeah school dance his
typewriters at the school dance hell
yeah that's what all the kids are into
drugs and
typing oh that's where the mom went to
the school dance
wait look
[Music]
out holy moly what is that is that the
plant saw earlier plant
monster oh no that's a giant
fly a giant fly about a giant bra man
pre
mantis
oh my God it's a it's a drunk playing
pray
[Music]
[Applause]
mantis right
[Music]
to it feels like a b movie sci-fi horror
when like you know big big bug creature
attacks the town yeah you have to come
up with something so freaky just have a
neck for it I
guess oh no my wagon
ear my wagon ear you cut yourself is my
face messed up yeah big time you look
exactly the
same make out perfect
time oh nope that's a werewolf
yep I do wish some more of the creatures
were more practical
though yeah the sets are but the
creatures all CG yeah like I feel like
this could have been practical
and it is not age well yeah the the
Snowman looked better the Werewolf of
fif swamp he can snow my
scent it's not working I have
to that boy smells strong Jack Black
brings a lot to this yeah he's on our TA
oh no oh
no get me up oh no no no keep
[Music]
going mom or is it the aunt I think it's
the YT yep I'm
okay I'm still okay she be perfect to
date RL Stein this is the back of my
store I didn't know where else to go I
can't get a hold of your mother or the
cops or
anyone yep I saw it in his face
immediately he's bewildered I'm lorine
hello arel Stein we owe you a great dead
of gratitude
yeah oh lorine lorine lorine we don't
have time I need you to go to the police
station and tell them to meet
us oh did you want to exchange numbers
is that a good timeing yes dang that
girl making his Goosebump for know
they're going to Goose
hump does everyone get it sex please
you're the SC
cat wait wait wait wait wait wait hold
on it's okay it's just a statue all
right you're fine it's not just a statue
have you not seen Doctor Who it's a
weeping angel don't blink it's C on your
jacket my
hero make out perfect time in between
danger right in front of her dad do it
champ interrupt
oh D are you right
maybe come on she something she's
something knew she wasn't human knew she
wasn't human oh she's dead she's a
ghost what are you a
ghost yeah yeah totally
I'm how about anology you just witness
zombies oh maybe she doesn't know oh
oh my God classic
zombies gouls
is hten get GS and zombies confused are
they one in the same I don't know I
thought ghouls were like an offshoot of
ghost calling all cops calling all the
cops can anyone hear me I can hear oh he
is still there
okay Sergeant Slappy Sergeant Slappy he
is like Chucky you're don't do it don't
say it dummy you
said wow they're just there on Q Hannah
doesn't know that she doesn't know what
that she's not
real she thinks she's a person okay not
not just some figment of your
imagination how could wow it's messed up
you have no idea how lonely it's been
until Hannah I wrote her in such a way
that she thinks she's real and she is
real to me Zach but the Moonlight
reveals it after my dad died I should
everyone out
too maybe we can both start
over if we're alive tomorrow no that's a
little tragic yeah or if we're going to
come across the Dilemma of if he has to
put all the characters back that
includes her as well or is it going to
find a way to save her how way you just
don't write yourself like the hottest
woman I was just thinking that just
write yourself a really hot wife
multiple hot
wives monster have invaded Madison they
they've blocked every road out of town
they they've torn down the cell towers
how do they still have power good
question he's right it's the Boogeyman
and he's picking his
nose who the hell are you guy hope a
creature snatches him there's a giant
bug and it's hitting everybody's cars
yeah it's getting old dude no
seriously that was actually a really
great
there are L Stein's monsters but we need
to buy him time to write and don't worry
he's a very quick writer the night was
cold cold was the
[Laughter]
[Music]
night Come Close don't be shy you don't
want to miss the show wow wa my god he
has an army it's Easter egg
[Applause]
[Music]
Central it plays out like a quirky
Goosebump story which is kind of neat
there's there's other really clever
about it it could be a better movie but
it's still really it's still really like
I I do appreciate its cleverness a lot
it's far from great but it's fun
you please no save her so you can date
the popular
girl oh my God that's your maneuver
you're going to get ripped a sh I
[Laughter]
know is way stronger than
you oh
okay whoa what is something do he have
silver on him I think he just bit him I
think his teethes he have a silver tooth
yeah Super Teeth oh
uming I have a ton of cavities when I
was T didn't brush my teeth for a whole
year it's so hot you saved my life CH
it's actually
champ oh she did call him Chum
earlier oh hell
[Music]
yeah God see he
practical but that one you could have
[Laughter]
C are you okay yeah than come with
me she looks hotter as a ghost
right right Aaron youever seen
[Laughter]
a it's like Space Jam a new Legacy if
all the characters were attacking
people I've been running away from
people my whole life I was so angry at
the real world that I created these
terrible monsters
I'm not mad anymore did RL sign approve
this like the real life RL
sign he's actually
suing it's been a loss for three years
like I don't like the way you're portr
[Music]
me man they get a lot of mileage out of
this uh what are they called CGI
uh Human Centipede not human CED called
PR mtis there we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah oh no that's a
bomb get
him oh clever clever clever the old
[Music]
Switcheroo holy
crap oh
Papa you left without saying
goodbye trying to hide from me oh looks
weird turned your back on me locked me
up imprisoned me in the pages of a book
do like that they give a more personal
relationship between Slappy and ARL
Stein say hello to my gous
friend it's the problem that H everyone
don't let it touch you oh my God I don't
know why something about this movie
maybe imagine Jack Black is the Joker
yeah it's he's doing something that
sounds like Mark Hill for Slappy
yeah
dude while you're at it man write
yourself a oh my God all right we have
to finish the book
okay they can't kill their creator can
they sure they can yeah my goal is to
kill God one
day you watch me get it
done they're coming what are we going to
do finish it Zach not going to lie I
don't like this champ guy he's kind of
annoying it's the only one I don't
like again the end there not like
Charming any fight no about to find
out
that's a real Ferris wheel yeah it's a
real Forest
too's a SE belt in this thing there's no
way they feel like I
was Whimsical part of the movie that I
just can't
believe you believe all the monsters I
believe everything else but like we've
all been on a ferris wheel
soy be like it's like crushing on the
ground it's like yeah hell no second
their seat hits the around here they go
flying wait what are you waiting for
come on open the book what all the
monsters except one oh yeah there's
something that you need to know and
you're not going to believe open the
book Zack no she knows she knows now
means it means be suck on a shelf some
place forever you know how many sweet
16s can one girl have a manstein you're
stupid can't just write her
aging take it all open
no bring her back Skybeam even
Goosebumps gets a sky beam hell
[Music]
yeah maybe if I hold on to you tight
enough you have to let go Zach just like
you let go of your dead
dad that's the theme of the story let go
Zach Happy's not happy neither is
Stein stupid dumy n
Stein you'll be okay I'll always be in
your
imagination which is really where I
belong I'm just sad we never got to
share a dance oh this is actually really
[Music]
sad I think they made Dyan manette kiss
the air
[Laughter]
I know you loved
her those 48 Hours you guys had it
together it's okay we're going to spend
the second movie trying to get her back
now that's probably why she comes back
that's probably was her second movie
damn oops bumps to two two bump
bumpier gooses geese we're all happy
where happy High
School no trauma at all look how happy
of a high school we are the law still
applies no time
[Laughter]
off you look great you smell great is he
teaching a literature course or creative
writing class course oh he's teaching
class algebra
hey every story ever told can be broken
down into three distinct parts
the beginning the middle and the
twist so it's the twist that's the real
RL
Stein he's the new Drama teacher
ah so he didn't sue not a day goes by
that I don't think of her but she'll
always be in
here and in there and also right over
[Music]
there ah a he wrote TST again they
genetically engineered
[Laughter]
her let's go does she you get a age nope
there's a lot of questions I have
here still 16 forever forever and
ever oh The Invisible Boy didn't get
destroyed
H yep you forgot about
[Music]
me nice yeah that's a good twist ending
let me see if there's a post credit
scene no I feel like The Invisible Boy
would have been the post credit scene
nerp nerp nerp it's 2015 alrighty
alrighty guys well if you're listening
to this on Apple or Spotify please rate
the video my friend Aaron
Alexander and myself their gorgeous Greg
Alba have just watched Goosebumps the
2015 movie because we've both never seen
it and you know algorithm [__] you are
it's there's a show coming out in Disney
Plus have you seen the trailer I heard
it's like Riverdale is it really
Goosebumps or something I I don't know I
didn't even know there's a show coming
out yeah it comes out on Disney plus I
think and it's it's supposedly Like A
M I don't know some like darker teen
investigation Shenanigans really like I
haven't seen the trailer so I I don't
know but I I've heard some people is
Jack coming back say those things no
it's not like it has nothing to do with
this that for some people say those
things both in a good tone and a
negative tone so the exact same
sentiments and uh yeah I think it's
going to
flop woof because you don't even know
about it do kids still watch you're the
tar you're the Target demographic yep my
28y old
ass It's Made For Me alrighty well um
let's talk about this yeah let's talk
about it uh I thought it was rated out
of 10 uh six wow that's a low
rating I mean it was what if what if we
added more numbers in there like like a
I can a five like a 6 point four five
you could add a do you want to add a
point do you feel a0 five or do you not
feel a0 five uh I mean like a Pity
point5 I did that I mean I would like I
feel like a six is like it's good I
guess if I saw like a 60 on Rotten
Tomatoes I'd be like they just a 60 is a
c so is a six then if we're doing six
out of 10
geez that's all it is 60 is 60 out of
100 six of 10 yeah 6 out of 10 it was I
think it was fun you know I appreciated
all of
the the stuff that was uh Goose bumpy uh
some good vocabulary there wrer real uh
real uh scholar scholar criticism here
uh no I thought it was fun I thought I
enjoyed the music and you know that the
performances are really cool I thought
Jack Black really did his thing was very
different from the roles we've seen him
do before uh something that I totes M
goats totes M goats uh something that I
didn't really like too much well I just
felt like it was got a little repetitive
towards the middle section it was just
like they're running and then it's get
out of that situation and then it be
running again and I feel like if you're
going to do something like that it
should have sort of a dual purpose you
know Advance the characters Advance the
plot at the same time but it felt like
it was just getting from one situation
to the next situation until we got to
the end of the movie um but yeah I mean
I there were some laughs there to be had
for sure I thought it was funny I I like
the the two leads including Jack Black I
like the three I didn't really like
champ all that much kind of like
yourself um but yeah it was cool it was
it was fun it was fine it didn't blow me
away I don't know it didn't like evoke
any like strong emotions in me but I had
fun with it you know I don't I don't
regret watching it it wasn't bad there
were some
holes here and there like logic
holes yeah all right what' you think
Greg 9.89 beautiful out of 10 hell yeah
I'm expecting it to go to 11 out of 10
by the time I'm I'm talking about
[Laughter]
okay no I I'd I'm more like a six
point yeah at 6.5 part of me wants to
bump it to s just out of effort and
intent the Practical sets were cool when
they when they had them but a lot of the
CGI was like yeah I mean like looking at
it in the Le like there's two ways to
look at at a movie right I think like a
good metric is we kind of based look at
it like RW and tomato the thing here
some don't people don't get about rawten
tomatoes is like people often compare
the critic score versus the audience
score so so if like a Critic score is
low but an audience score is high mhm
people are like see critics don't know
what they're talking about the
difference is critics are watching like
a billion movies all the time and they
have a different type of metric and
expectation of film making standard
where an audience scorer the people who
are voting in that audience score for
said movie are the demographic or the
audience that they are aiming to tend to
that the movie is aiming to tend to and
they're chiming in to say if they like
really liked it or not you know um so
that's just like my Litt as side so I
can so one part of me is saying that
because I'm going all
right if there if the aim is to get like
the Goosebumps the people who liked
reading Goosebumps or or watching
Goosebumps I'm sure there's and like
really know the monsters and stuff I can
see one scenario where they just like
seeing this [__] pop up on screen they
have fun it's a lot of the Leonard
DiCaprio Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
meme of like oh I know that creature oh
I know you know a lot of that yeah which
is like every movie now but um but yeah
there's there's a lot of that that I
think you could enjoy Easter egg the
movie and on top of that too
um this one is clearly targeted because
because Goosebumps exists at least when
I was growing up where it was actually
it could be actually really SC at least
from a sometimes you watch some of the
clips or whatever you're like
it's cheesy but actually they really
commit to the like it's Camp be but it's
still it's still a Horror Story oh yeah
it's still they still Peril and it's
still spooky and
creepy um and some at times unnerving
while goofy it it's still a horror
story this is not that this is not a
horror it's got like a backdrop and a
setting so it feels like the target
audience is more to be
familyfriendly yeah I could see how you
can get away with more trying to go
horror when you're doing like a a show
but when you're trying to sell them big
dollars really trying to sell them on on
on true like kid fear horror I I I don't
even feel like a kid would be scared
watching that you know what I mean no uh
it still it still settles more into like
like other than a couple of moments with
like Slappy perhaps the dog like with
the jump scare yeah other than like a
little bit like that there's no actual
scene so I feel like the target audience
that they're aiming for perhaps they do
feel satisfied uh I I really don't know
I don't know what the responces I just
wanted to watch it because it's
Goosebumps um and and they and you know
algorithm and and it's been on the list
and I and I have wanted to see the movie
so I was like yeah it's perfect timing
the on my personal side I like
everything that uh you said you liked um
I do agree I second that Jack Black I
thought really elevated this a lot like
he really I think is a major
contributing factor to what really
helped out this this because what he
just have like surprise moments where
you just don't see like a joke come like
I love that the setup of like it's like
towards the end of the movie where I'm
like I keep checking in and out of the
film and and they have that line uh when
he's writing he's like he's a fast rider
and he's like the night was cold he just
pauses goes cold was the night he rips
it out and starts over that was so
funny it's a great joke it's a really
like great joke and it's visually funny
and you need the right editing for that
so like stuff like that I really
enjoyed uh Slappy I thought they they
put the most emphasis on and I will say
the thing that really really undercut
the
experience was exactly what you what you
pointed out and that was the thing that
stood out to me of like that's why this
movie is kind of becoming numb and
dull
is I can't like they there's nothing
really distinguishable about the
characters other than their
look or or I guess size you know like oh
I yeah there's a difference between like
a ghoul on ground versus a massive um
[__] um what do you call them God
dang what are they pray man the pre
mantis yes there's a difference between
a massive pre mantis and a ghoul on
but it is the same bit over and over
again it's very repetitive they
just run into a situation where they're
there it doesn't really seem like
there's truly any physical danger or
Stakes because they're easy to give the
slip all the time even when it seems
like they're trapped they no one ever
gets injured it doesn't really feel like
there's any weight behind any of these
moments no and I I feel like if granted
you could still do those things but if
it was coupled with something like maybe
the thing they're they're fighting has
to do with like some uh character Arc
they have to go through like maybe it's
some mirror version of like something of
the character's experience or the
character gets injured like they're put
in a situation where they have to
overcome something but it never really
got to that point never it just kind of
the same thing over and over and they
were safe there was no Stakes there was
no there was never
any problem solving yeah to just running
it's just it's here get away from it
yeah you know there's no real thought on
defeat like the only way to defeat them
is you got to open the book you know and
but there's no way to escape the situ it
would have been more more fun if there
was per character if there was something
you had to do to like like RL Stein What
do we do to get out of the situation
it's like all right is this thing like
it's a trap of the werewolf like how do
we get the werewolf get out of it's but
just everything just goes back to run
away from it and get away yeah that
could have been interesting like with
him being the writer if he knew every
Monster's weakness I could have added to
the scenario yeah that way it's not just
repetitive and it so just does become
repetitive and there's no real and the
character stuff they just like heavy
Exposition like sprinkle in some heavy
Exposition once in a while to get
whereas I thought like I was actually
enjoying that before the Goosebump stuff
happened that's that's the weird part
like I was actually really enjoying the
first like half hour before the
Goosebump [__] started kicking in of
this guy moving to this town and a
friending this girl and then there's
like the weird neighbor in the mystery
of the neighbor and then like oh is she
getting killed upstairs like there was
it was it was really fun actually yeah
and it's when the actual plots happened
where it it kind of just it's like a car
that just speeds to 100 and then starts
losing gas really fast yeah and it just
but it's still speeding on the freeway
the entire time yeah no I agree with
that I think
that yeah also the humor in the latter
half of the movie wasn't working as well
for me cuz especially those like bits
with like the the mom and the the
teacher that kept popping up and then I
never found a champ funny at really any
point really annoying yeah right like he
was like really annoying that character
normally works in like is he an adult
now so I can make fun of him I mean it's
like eight years ago so take itan
probably be an adult now right yeah he
was
annoying If this just came out today I
would be like we should go soft he's a
kid he's an adult now he should to take
the cyber bully he's a grown ass
man I've not seen this kid in the movie
since I am impervious to being coms and
cyber bullying so let me let me lay it
on you for your performance years ago
roast [__] this
kid no he's it is an annoying but
there's no I I don't blame him I I think
I think he's act I'm not just saying it
to like save face you I think he's
actually believable able as that
character I think the character is
annoying um he's not like charmingly
frightened it it
doesn't I think there's a thing there is
the beat there where he rises to the
occasion and saves the girl because he's
so afraid but but the movie's so busy
with its repetitive set pieces that you
don't get time to really latch on
to I'm not even asking we're not asking
for like a deep character study or some
[__] I'm just like talking Basics here
just Basics enough to get you latched
onto the adventure at hand and uh yeah
like by the time he even saves a girl I
didn't even register till right now like
oh there it is he's overcoming his fear
I guess oh
yeah like the moment oh yeah yeah I
guess what he was doing but like I don't
think you like added anything to the
movie like no there like when they were
when they were a trio and they didn't
really feel like a group necessarily it
felt like the the main character the
girlfriend ARL Stein and then he was
just there
yeah yeah yeah I like the I like the the
two like I actually felt really bad for
the girl when she was like getting did
she was getting ghosted yeah they
created like an this interesting
conflict that they resolved immediately
and I was like oh I would have liked if
we like at least would have let that
linger until the second movie teach this
thing about loss you know it's like a
doctor who Cliffhanger yeah whenever the
episode has a cliffhanger how will they
get out out of the situation prologue of
the next episode they are out of the
situation anyone who wants to start
Doctor Who I'm preparing you right now
that is most of Doctor
Who yeah man I mean yeah I haven't seen
dror who in a minute but you're not
wrong that is the general structure Dr
oh no Cliffhanger I got to tune in next
week oh good thing I tuned in for that
opening scene cuz they are now out of
that Peril on to the next situation
good for them
right um but yeah I
mean it's just it's a movie that I think
does it could it warrants I don't think
you I think you could ask for more
creativity from a movie that is about a
dude who is super creative like you can
you it it does it does feel like it
other than just member berries for
Goosebumps which is kind of weird
considering that like sure it was a
popular show but a lot of people don't
remember the show and then the books
it's that's a form of literature so make
these characters come to life the the
creatures come to life in a way that's
truly distinguishable or you you really
see um something like you need you need
some type of implementation of getting
visually creative or some or setpiece
creative yeah I mean as we're talking
about this I'm kind of wondering who is
this movie for is it to intr ucing kids
to a newer audience but then I little
kids and people who read Goosebumps but
even the kids who like Goosebumps right
wouldn't they want something that's more
spooky to invoke the experience of what
they went through as a child I don't
know might be good enough we eat up
member berries in our society you know
how we are true we're Nostalgia based
culture that just loves everything that
is just I know that I mean people I do
it sometimes people didn't like uh Space
Jam 2 and that was all member bar that
wasn't really member berries no that was
all IPS it wasn't really me member
berries work more in the sense of uh of
like the world that it's living in not
IP not that is just like Warner Brothers
properties right but it's not a real
world um but this is like a world of of
of like the Goosebumps books you know or
like Star Wars does their memberberries
and Mar Marv and you know they they
they're weaker now to us though they
don't work as strong on us anymore M
don't we've we've built up resistance we
expect quality now I know bunch of
[__] yeah [__] trash I miss just
watching something and going I know that
thing I'm happy I'm satisfied as a man
I'm you did something I
[Laughter]
know I'm bricked
up uh
yeah I think honestly they should have
they should have just like paired it
down to a few things instead of like a
bunch of things yeah yeah and and then
they would have they they streamlined it
because it's like their load early by
doing all of them yeah so much yeah so
much and I'm telling you guys I I I
still over like the first half I I was
really enjoying and then the last half
be I was a real intermittent experience
for me
so I still Edge my way
towards if this was Rotten Tomatoes I
would still be fresh okay I would still
be fresh I just I just barely cross the
th it's like when you you go to the
store and you
go are these bananas actually still good
well there's no black spots on it yet
so all right I guess I'll go get them
just got to make sure to eat it within
three four days probably sooner yep or
it's going to make you sick or else it's
going to oxidate fast yeah that's
Goosebumps the movie to
me Goosebumps the movie Just Like Old
bananas just like bananas that are about
to go
bed I mean yeah man it's the chair man
it's the armrest it's the
armrest of a new attitude now you're so
cool thought I got a wave a pen around
now so your body language it does
everything for you yeah man makes you
calm make you chill um yeah man I
thought it was a
[Music]
six we're passing 645 out of kindness
for me all right guys what would you
rate Goosebumps the movie uh leave your
thoughts down below when do you decide
do you buy bananas when they're really
green because it's like there's like
that sweet spot for a banana you know
like they need to be like they need to
be yellow but when they're green I don't
like the taste of that some people like
it that way really they're not sweet
enough I know they're hard too
yeah go eat your hard bananas you yeah
you do something else with hard bananas
you wait for them to go
yellow what do you said that's what you
do baby anyway guys I'm ready to shout
out this Patron so I can get Aon out of
here Daddy pancakes who are you Danny
pancakes my God I think this is the
first time I don't know if John shouted
you out last month is this your first
month getting a patron of the day shout
out no whoa oh I think you've just
upgraded to or no I don't think I've
ever seen your name before Am I Wrong Am
I a jerk right now for not Danny
pancakes okay we're g to shout you out
right now Danny um Danny pancakes you uh
I want to feed you a bunch of steaks I'm
going to go to your lawn and all those
leaves are going to get raked and then
we're going to take out a cake and have
it be baked and we can bake some
pancakes and while we're at it we can
put some protein powder into a shake so
you're getting a little bit healthy then
they start calling you healthy Danny and
then I'll slap you on the bed the Buns
you go Danny Fanny and then you're going
to get get me cancelled cancel gregy
Danny cancel gregy oh
[Music]
shitty it's the movie Man
SC put me in a weird mood super chill
it's the armrest it's the armrest
dude Danny pancakes Danny Danny pancakes
shouting them out oh come on ER I'm
trying what the hell I'm I'm a written
man listen I like freestyling but I'm
I'm a written man what the hell I'm a
man of the the script not a script but
like I'm a poet for those of you guys
who don't know Danny Danny you're a
great guy I love you Danny special man
dude here's what we're going to do we're
going to use chat gbt right now all
right write me a
poem a rap for Danny
pancakes make sure every line rhymes
with Danny
pancakes let's see what you do let's see
if you can talk me chat gbt
me all right
Aaron Danny pancakes staing knacking up
them Hot Cakes flipping them high no
room for the mistakes with syrup and
butter no fake hand
shakes say fad yeah yeah D breakfast
Kingpin Watch the Throne he takes the
chorus oh my god there a chorus Danny
pancakes serving them up no breaks eat
every bright you take feel like a dream
that awakes griddle on fire every
morning he bakes love the breakfast love
the hot cakes there's no hot in there
that's okay Maple and berries with
whipped cream
Lakes flavor so fly give you taste but
Quakes don't know in the diner you don't
know Daddy pancakes is a
Pur she reming about pancakes let's go
in the diner with every move he makes
legend in the kitchen sets high stakes
Danny
pancakes all right that's that's enough
all right we did it we did the thing
damn CH gbt is gonna replace
us slowly but surely this how Drake's
been writing his RS all oh
100% know
it all right we're done you did it
thanks Danny for being here
[Music]
h